hello and welcome to this video playing
lunatic ex Grandmaster I keep forgetting
that we holic yes yeah I don't have a
couple of games already against them
have a pretty bad score but I think I
had decent positions if i remember
correctly so we get done the italian
game this is so popular nowadays and i
have some issues with this really i
don't quite I don't quite understand the
subtleties down okay if it was not be
too busy to I have this g5 attack which
is interesting and I think good form for
black we should be three years son it's
amazing often you can get that okay well
let's see what happens
I've had this on the board quite a bit
so I'm going to not spend on spend on
ages here on my moves a tick here is he
going Queen f3 or something f 7s hanging
I can do bishop cheer for it's not it's
not entirely ridiculous now what is he
actually playing and set Teague stakes
I'm ready f to hang so let's take with
the bishop it's also quick development I
mean Queenie one hmm doesn't look all
that scary I see no was doing that hmm
okay so what's what's the thing yeah
magia I've got the g file open I would
like to let the castle right Castle long
castles loan would be good so maybe just
27 when you Scott this before stuff okay
does he have some tactic there I don't
know come on let's play it let's just
play the move and then see what happens
so let's get out of this so what's
happening here we show each three
if you please look after i think i could
have sacrificed ok i'm here and then
queen age three that is not enough he is
basically claiming possible
I take twice on G to check on g8 is
going to have to angle Queen h3
threatening look g2 made you can tutor
tutor check you can go to f2 there I can
eat you I mean and I have the check well
I'm sorry I'm sacrificing like
everything so it sounds a little bit
much it's a bit too much so what's
what's going on here maybe I just
doubling its double maybe taking too
long a very complicated position it
might be okay for black well it's a
different difficult thing to play really
don't know don't quite know what's going
on outside of my weaknesses there on the
add file okay so it guys covering it up
like that 93 I don't know 93 and maybe
this and then Queen to e7 but you can
kill this again if I go give me 7 right
here it doesn't threaten much doesn't
threaten all that much okay actually I
think I should bring the night or maybe
maybe it just takes f7 hear ya Wow hey
might just take it
you might just take bishop at seven and
asked me what my compensation is yeah I
think that's that that's a move damn it
my route gangs and my night Hank nothing
again of course just a bloody blunder
here yeah what a stupid time for what a
stupid move yeah that's losing it's not
solely lost just one move and then it's
gone that's always annoying it was a
difficult position I don't know what's
what's going on maybe I should have
chicken on g4 with the night at the
beginning I don't know I really think
that is that this isn't particularly
grateful wide the waiter odd was totally
unclear yeah it was just nothing here
yeah whatever doesn't matter it's a very
easy win for why now no attack
whatsoever
check
just no threat okay that's a good way to
do it check now also laughs absolutely
no time on the clock hey I was very
tough very tough you have to step on the
board quite a bit and I think I'm black
chances are excellent en some night
takes is the better movie on I wasn't
sure some night takes I really think
that why shouldn't play like that with
age three and allow this g5 business
which is very dangerous um okay so night
takes with what would have been better
this is how I usually play but it wasn't
sure what happens after this just Queen
to e7 yeah anyway I thought this also
was interesting so we should be three
and two kids and nine th five ok this is
this is some the engine wants to do this
and then and then maybe do something
else according what white is doing gives
me a slight edge but this is a very
murky position very murky position but
should be six ahead makes an awful lot
of sense in hmm yeah that's what the
engine won't see that makes a lot of
sense that Bishop became very annoying
on the F file and trading here's is
really useful something like this which
the engine assesses is equal this is
something that I can believe somehow and
I've got some stuff on the G file going
white has something on the F fraud at
five is weak now it could easily somehow
balance balance each other out again we
should be six is strong I didn't
understand that I felt that this is
dangerous
okay so this this andrew TJ token it
doesn't help I know I'm computer sense
i'm winning all the time ninety-seven is
bad yeah 93 is better what it's
complicated it's complicated i just
blundered at seven of course making it
very easy for him yeah okay it's not
that I didn't think of this move but
what I didn't really kind of have on the
radar is that I should just go back this
is just very um very logical once you
think of it yeah this is Bishop is
always putting this pressure and it's
not quite clear if my bishop is doing
that much on g2 it's like protected a
million times and um yeah here I can't
hear not worse I mean the engine since
its +1 something for black but things
here I'm not losing f7 or anything this
is just what I should do um it gives
night f1 as the line uh-huh and then
Queen to d8 it's a cool night f5 night
eggs check this is this is the engines
mainline something like that and this is
of course excellent yeah for black I
have a slightly better porn structure
and the pressure on the G file that's
really nice yeah that that was
blundering the gamer taking is not
exactly difficult yeah saw it after
playing the 97 was very stupid and took
to quite a bit of time there there was
some idea i mean the night currently
isn't doing anything at all but if i
want to regroup it i would have needed
to go here to keep this protected this
isn't all that bad especially if I
intend to go we should be six later mm
okay I was a tough game tough game he
defended this quite quite well I mean
why does white is really in some trouble
there if you if you take some some bad
play people
just lose this pretty pretty much easily
and he managed to keep it within
reasonable on proportions that white is
not like losing immediately he's just
just clearly worse let's say but in a
difficult way it wasn't it wasn't all
that easy 97 or ever it's kind of
annoying it's pretty easy it's really
easy to refute it's not like i was
putting much problems here for him okay
well thanks for watching